les chéris îles d'hyères séquence de fou
dans l'émission vous l'avez vu avec
notre rené malleville un bien sûr
reviennent fort que j'embrasse qui sera
toujours mon pote d'ailleurs et je vais
aller le voir très prochainement à
marseille benjamin et jean-michel se
sont expliqués face à rené et malgré les
tentatives de réconciliation
rené a maintenu sa position a décidé
pour l'instant
à notre grand regret de quitter
l'émission espère tous ici que c'est
provisoire
vous allez me donner votre sentiment va
vous raconter ce qui s'est passé après
l'émission d'ailleurs avec rené ces
partis hier soir rené malleville était
de retour sur le plateau de thé pmp pour
s'expliquer après les échanges tendus de
la veille dans l'émission mais plus
croire coûte maintenant tu te crois quoi
là le chroniqueur n'avait pas accepté
les rires de benjamin castaldi et jean
michel maire qu'il a pris
personnellement comme de la moquerie
voire du bizutage suis pas là pour faire
le comique de la maman et jean-michel
ont tenu à présenter leurs excuses à
rené pour eux il n'y avait rien de
malveillance simplement envie de
s'amuser je regrette sincèrement du fond
du coeur s'il était blessé parce que
c'est pas du tout toi voulait baisser
mais ses excuses n'ont pas été
suffisantes pour rené qui dans un
discours particulièrement émouvant nous
a expliqué qu'ils sont et siffler la fin
de la récré il y en a beaucoup vivent à
marquer je m'ennuie je te fais un gros
bisou et un départ très touchant il faut
dire qu'on a un peu moins de trois mois
à l'antenne rené avait conquis le coeur
de nombreux téléspectateurs
alors comprenez vous la décision de rené
de quitter la famille
on vous demande à vous poser la question
mais entendu et hier soir après avec
rené on a pris ça chez nous on a bu un
petit pastis a bien sûr rappelé un câble
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé on
a bu un petit pastis avec mon run et
dans ma loge on s'est bien marré m'a
raconté plein d'histoires et il était
très très heureux voilà qu'on boive un
petit coup ensemble je fais des gros
bisous et j'espère que c'est provisoire
nicolas pernikoff on l'a vu on l'a vécu
hier soir rené c'est quelqu'un
d'authentiqué de sincère qui réfléchit
pas qui voit là ils disent qu'ils
pensent c'est un mec c'est un vrai mec
c'est un vrai mec honnête et je pense
qu'il a été à titre personnel touché sa
famille surtout puisque il nous a parlé
beaucoup d'émotion de l'a22 les
discussions qu'il avait eues avec son
épouse la nuit où ils avaient ils
avaient tous les deux pleurer et pas non
plus voilà ça mais après chacun vit les
choses différemment
sait il l'a mal vécu son épouse l'a mal
vécu il s'est senti un peu un peu un peu
con qu'on me le tout le monde ça peut
être le ressenti qu'il a eus je sais je
sais bien ils jean-michel ou benjamin ne
sont pas des gens méchants noter que
personne autour de cette table des
méchants maintenant ce qu'il faut
accepter c'est qu'il ait pu mal le vivre
que son épouse qui à des milliers de
kilomètres et puis mal le vivre que ses
enfants et ses petits enfants aient pu
mal le vivre
il n'a pas forcément l'habitude de la
télévision vous savez bien que la
télévision est plutôt un métier à un
monde un petit peu violent nous on en a
l'habitude
mais quand vous arrivez ici on est un
peu dans un monde de bisounours au pool
dirais mais bien sûr les pmp c1 ce
maillot quand on parle de famille c'est
pas un truc de fou qu on est vraiment le
taux spot
entre nous on s'entend plutôt tous bien
quand quelqu'un n'est plus là pendant
quelques semaines moi je sais que ça a
été mon cas on passe un petit coup de
fil pour prendre de mes nouvelles
voilà c'est ça l'ambiance de tpp et on
est là pour se marrer on est là pour
rigoler encore plus aujourd'hui et c'est
ce que vous voulez aussi en dix ans la
tournée lady en ce moment il ya le
quotidien que des merdes on est confiné
essayons de faire rire les gens au
maximum ses salars c'est tout alors un
jour me bon moi je comprends qu'il ait
décidé de partir non pas parce que je
souhaitais qu'ils partent parce que
majorité eric ress n'ont pas non plus
que je pense que ça mérite et qui part
parce que je pense était jamais qu'à une
émission on se marre bien sûr voilà mais
je pense qu' il n'était pas formaté pour
ça sert que la dérision et
l'autodérision sireix est une vertu que
tout le monde na na pas dans le même
semble même à 73 ans aussi
sur ces prêts sont génération une
question d'âge il a l'habitude
construite 2 j parce qu'il est respecté
par sa famille ses petits en fonction de
tera c'est normal voilà mais on a tous
eu voilà on a tous été moquée dans cette
émission là moi peut-être même plus que
dois je refoulais talents tout en
longueur du temps etc
et c'est vrai qu'il faut bien le prendre
après on a certainement abusé mais ça
méritait pas de partir mais s'il ne sent
pas ça aurait fini par craquer donc
autant qu'ils partent avant que ça
déborde
guillaume moi je pense que c'est une
erreur de sa part c'est un excellent
chroniqueur rooney avec un vrai
personnage un vrai persoons l'a vu dans
les manuels taux de rôle sur lui dire
c'était c'était super je pense qu'il a
mr mal pris effectivement ce qui ce qui
s'est dit et surtout il a été très
touché par le fait que sa famille ait
souffert et parce qu'il a pris la
décision à chaud mais surtout je pense
qu'il va changer d'avis tpm pc une
famille dans une famille on s'aime on se
déteste on se fâche et on peut revenir
mais je souhaite y reviendra inouïe nous
aimons il a ma chérie en arts tient prêt
aux divers avec lui on soyez tout à fait
on a beaucoup ri devant le droit je ne
vois pas et puis il était tiraillé dans
le fait de ne pas de regretter du tout
sa décision il vouloir s'y tenir
et puis le fait qu'il était bien dans le
bureau avec nous tous à boire un pastis
en nous expliquant comment 2ème pas si
on voulait pas qu'il soit raté et c'est
même plaisanté sur le fait que le site
avait été là tu aurais pu compter là
dessus
en revanche je suis pas d'accord quand
tu dis il était pas formaté pour ça si
nous a tellement plu c'est justement
parce qu'il est parfois un jeu wii jean
michel aulas qui n'est pas formaté donc
là moi aussi j'espère comme guillaume
que parce que moi je regarde apprendre à
aimer c'est tous les soirs assise à côté
de lui confirmer avec eva regarder
apprendre
kubla la x1 vous pouvez pas savoir ah
oui je sais je les merdes avec qui je
vais regarder
oui je sais je sais bernard bernard non
mais je sais que c'est un homme hyper
sensible et que moi je regrette vraiment
son départ on s'entendait très bien moi
il me faisait rire c'est un mec
extraordinaire ça mais qui parle très
naturellement
et ce côté là était extrêmement
intéressant chez lui et puis d'une très
grande gentillesse je suis vraiment
désolé de son départ vraiment parce que
non commencés en plus ça nous a fait un
truc très sympathique mais depuis six
mois je vais bien a dit hier isabelle tu
vas me dire il nous a dit j'ai vécu des
moments exceptionnels ici je me suis
régalé c'est ce qui nous a dit hier et
qui ça il est il a passé des moments
voilà je pense qu' il actifs et 99% du
temps il y avait ce petit truc voit la
wii la wii c'est que je comprends voilà
il a évidemment parce qu'on n'a pas
notre âge non plus on l'aimé tant que
comme c'est quelqu'un qui est très
ouvert ouais ça intéressait pas qu aux
chroniqueurs que contrairement à
d'autres voilà amauri à alexandre
assistera encore longtemps vivre
daniel moi j'ai le sentiment d'un
immense gâchis d'un malentendu parce que
j'avais comme alentours du ccas j'étais
à côté de lui le jour de l'émission j'ai
trouvé tellement touchant avec ses
feuilles qu'il avait écrit à la main
santé qui l'avaient bios et on s'entend
qu'il savait parler avec les kids a été
d'accord machette continuer ses clichés
tels roomba c'est drôle oui je suis et
oui si hélas qu'il n'est pas formaté
forme il est naturellement drôle c'est
que vous allez me confirmer si on a ri
moi j'ai j'avoue j'ai ri aussi
et parce qu'il y avait le tartarin a
bien sûr et on salit france à nous à ça
nous a tués
c'est de ça dont on n'arrive plus et
puis rené eu quand il était sur sa
chaîne locale sur laquelle il est
toujours à marseille
il faisait déjà rire tout le monde tout
le monde criait mon pas de lui mais avec
lui je suis sûr qu'il est a su que quand
vous l'avez fait venir dans tpm pedder
c'était pendant confinement il a su que
vous alliez rire un peu avec lui c'est
normal c'est l'adn encore une fois de
l'émission mais moi je reste persuadé
que rené va quand même revenir nous
faire un bisou parce que c'est un mec
qui est droit dans ses bottes il a voulu
partir il nous l'a dit reçoit avec
émotion et j'espère juste que tout le
monde se tapera dans la même pâte en
effet la baisse aussi à sa femme et ses
enfants allaient prendre un pv
parce que c'est ça et j'espère qu'il va
leur faire plaisir et puisque tout n'est
pas allé trop vite aussi en train parce
que la décision est peut être un peu
rapide mais c'est très vite attend
nombre d sont un petit peu à mon amie
audrey vous devenir ou année entière à
ce qu'il arrive à prendre
effectivement qui va réfléchir avec sa
famille qui va sûrement peut-être
revenir sur le plateau en tout cas c'est
ce qu'ont nasa tu as suivi la faire non
je peux suivre dévoile à rené malleville
à qu'on adore balade à vélo voilà mais
il va jeudi magani casque ans
conviennent tous ici un petit peu en
bande de copains effectivement je te
rejoins là dessus et on se moque tous de
nous même moi je me moque de moi même
aussi je suis la première à rigoler
quand on sort j'y pense qu'il est tout
simplement peut-être pas prêt justement
à rigoler à ça mais moi je vous ai
demandé je les dis est ce que j'ai un
conseil à me donner on m'avait dit kif
m'avait dit ça droit dans les yeux a
patiemment on vient en plateau et que ça
nous touche à ce point là et qu à ce
point là on pleure je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un moment où il
faut mieux partir parce qu'on n'est pas
là pour souffrir et je pense que vous le
comprenez totalement et voilà messi
s'est blessé sur la séquence et il était
tellement premier degré est tellement à
coeur avec ce sujet paraît que nous on
éléments que le deuxième voire le
troisième degré donc s'attaquer à créer
la différence après o'neill à 73 ans
anna entier fred est incertaine est
réussi ou non ses portes un peu moins la
boutade est la moquerie toujours avec le
fond bienveillant rythme ça me suis posé
la question de me dire comment aurait
réagi coupé honda nos grands-pères ouais
voilà et je pense qu'il aurait réagi
comme rené je vous dis la vérité je
pense qu'il aurait ravi comme on dit je
me suis posé la question
daniel plus connais peut-être c'est son
épouse qui a emporté la décision et
c'est vrai qu'il faut comprendre en fait
nous on est entre nous donc chevannes on
adore ça on allait autodérision mais moi
je vois parfois dans mon entourage
les gens qui m'aiment bien me dis donc
qu'est ce qui t'a mis l'autre jour je
dis mais attends mais c'est chez henri
avec avec moi et on rit pas contre moi
mais lui par la télé ça peut être
déformé je comprends que les
téléspectateurs à prévoir que benjamin
le pot ça a été compliqué pour lui oui
62% non à 38% c'est un petit peu comme
ici